foreign
picture 13 year old David
braces
bowl cut
Brown plaid shorts that seemingly don't
match with anything at all Standing Tall
at four foot eleven and for the very
first time about to step into a small
plane not as a passenger but as a pilot
I started flying lessons when I was 13
years old
I still vividly remember my first fight
lesson as I climbed into the cockpit the
smell of old musty leather permeated the
air
I was so short I had to sit on phone
books just to see over the dash
I was surrounded by a sea of confusing
gauges and dials buttons on my left
switches on my right it was overwhelming
my instructor was explaining the flight
controls to me and soon indicated that I
would be taking over
and my heart started to pound
I was gripped with fear
how is I supposed to manipulate this
seemingly impossibly complex vehicle
we taxied out to the runway Inn I slowly
Advance the throttle forward
the airplane lurched into action
building AirSpeed going faster and
faster and faster until
we ever so gently lifted under the air
I was flying and everything changed
the feelings of fear and anxiety were
washed away by wonderment and excitement
and pure joy
you see fly and unlock something truly
special for me it was a sense of Freedom
like no other
the ability to soar above communities
and taken life from a fresh perspective
it was truly freeing yet
one thing always frustrated me
flying wasn't practical
it was either a rigid time intensive
expensive process used to connect to far
away cities or
a hobby for fun that just didn't quite
make sense for daily life
well that all changed one day the summer
of 2017. right here in the San Francisco
Bay
because on that day I saw an air taxi
fly
well to be fair not quite an air taxi
this could better be likened to a
electric flying jet ski but on that day
I saw the power of electric propulsion
enable what I like to call personal
Aviation
the intersection of flight
with our daily lives
I was so inspired that day that I went
on to work at Hyundai and at Boeing as a
conceptual designer working to bring
Vehicles like this just a little closer
to reality
now the air taxi industry has come a
long way since that day in 2017.
there are over 200 companies working
across the space which is blossomed into
an industry called Urban Air Mobility
UAM for short
UAM is essentially the aerial Rideshare
services that utilize Vehicles often
referred to as evitos standing for
electric vertical takeoff and Landing
you can think of these vehicles as the
flying Ubers of the sky that take off
and land vertically from local helipad
terminals called fertiports
now let me pause here and note that when
you talk air taxis people tend to think
flying cars and of course
The Jetsons well
let me dispel some myths sadly these
vehicles won't be taken off and Landing
from your driveway and unless you have a
couple million dollars to spare you
probably won't be owning the EV tall
aircraft yourself and at least the
extent of my knowledge know these
vehicles won't be folding up into
briefcases but the ability to commute to
and from work via the air
maybe not too far off
picture this
you live in Santa Cruz but you have a
flight out of SFO in just a couple hours
you open your Rideshare app and one of
the options is an air taxi so you book
it
a vehicle comes to your door and drops
you off at the local verdeport just a
few minutes away
there you board awaiting Evita aircraft
Which flies you 15 minutes over the
mountains to over to Port SFO where it's
a short walk to the Passenger Terminal
round trip 25 minutes
now compare that to if you had driven
the hour plus Drive coupled with traffic
and the frustration that we know so
deeply here in the Bay Area
and the cost yeah comparable to an Uber
sounds a bit far-fetched right well let
me tell you where we're at today
there are hundreds of companies working
across their taxi industry from the
vehicles themselves to vertaport
infrastructure to autonomy to Battery
Technology and Regulatory development
you may not be able to tell the
difference between a Boeing and an
Airbus but take a look at a lot of the
vehicles across the industry there are
Stark differences and this is exciting
this is exciting because it represents
one of the largest Aerospace design
challenges in the past 50 years and as a
conceptual designer that's pretty
freaking cool
but
beyond the vehicles themselves the
intersection of air taxis with our daily
lives is at the vertaport
now vertaports are largely targeted
towards more urban settings but their
Concepts ranging from at airport
locations to various points of interest
even to more rural sites
there's even Concepts like this one from
Urban airport which depict how
vertaports can be thought of more as a
customer-centric experience a more akin
to commercial air terminals
now vertaports are largely in the
concept phase but they provide an early
look at the future of cities
to illustrate this let me refer to
Marchetti's constant
now Marchetti's constant states that the
average commute throughout history this
about 30 minutes each way an hour total
why does this matter well this matters
because the commute shapes our cities
ballet of example let's turn back in
time to ancient Paris and ancient Rome
which the time both locking cities
as we progress with rail we see London
in 1870
and then early street cars in 1915
Chicago
and then finally the automobiles we know
today in Atlanta in 2010.
our method of transportation
fundamentally shapes the fabric of our
cities
it affects where we live where we work
and who we connect with
as Battery Technology progresses over
the next decade to enable more and more
range out of air taxi services UAM is
poised to expand this yet again
just think how your life would be
different
if close by could be cities apart
now
actually there's still a ways out from
any sort of cost or scale comparable to
ground-based ride share
regulatory Pathways still have a lot of
ways to go before they're fully in place
early prototypes are still years out for
mass production
airspace can't handle low-level air
traffic at scale and notably a whole lot
of infrastructure still has to be
developed but
what I'm so enthused about is even if
you don't agree with the Bold
performance claims or operational cost
targets or development timelines
UAM is coming and it will affect each of
you
there are many challenges ahead but
these challenges represent we're on the
cusp of creating something truly
impactful from scratch
we're at an inflection point now
where every small decision can propagate
into huge impacts in the future
I hope you'll join 13 year old David and
bringing this journey of bringing the
freedom of flight
a little closer to reality
and I'll leave you with a quote that
hangs beside my bed
the best way to predict the future
is to create it
thank you